there are many differences among
conservatives on a whole host of issues
but on certain fundamental issues there
really does seem to be agreement
including the genius of the founders of
the United States and I believe it was
genius when I will say the term and it
strikes most Americans as worthy of a
yawn limited government they don't
understand the Holiness the goodness of
that
idea governments created every single
genocide of the 20th century why people
put Faith in big government they laugh
at people who put faith in God in Christ
in in the Bible are you kidding in terms
of irrationality you win heads down with
faith in government yeah I mean most of
the killing Mo 99% the only
non-governmental Slaughter of the 20th
century was the Ho to slaughtering the
tootsies that was the only
non-governmental Slaughter but 99% of
the of the 100 million
slaughtered not not combat not these are
not combatants right not people in in
the War uh was done by big
government all right Prager you get no
intro because because we're doing this
like every other week at this point oh
that is funny I I whether it's in La
Florida now we're in London but we
basically this is like your fifth time
on the show in the last seven days and I
love it uh it's fine with me what do you
think about this Arc thing we got to
tell a better story and maybe we can fix
some of what's going on with the
world so it's very it's a very
interesting question it doesn't sound
like it's this interesting question you
know what do you think of this
Gathering but I I get strength from it
that there are people from many parts of
the world
here you know and of I will say I
probably shouldn't but I I don't
self-censor much I will tell you on a
very personal
note that there is a deep sense of
gratification gratitude in in me the
number of people who come over to me
mostly
young are from different parts of the
world say that I've touched their life
prer you has touched their
life because you feel it too you know
we're we do a lot of our work when we're
not speaking obviously in front of an
audience alone you sit in a room and you
talk you don't know if you don't know
anyone is watching you don't know anyone
is not sure they're turn everything on
so when a man comes over to be three
came over to me from Albania why do you
to know you have such an impact in
Albania and I think really I didn't say
that to the guy but I'm thinking really
that that's I'll tell you how this is my
wife is going to crack up who's in the
room for totally random reasons the
Emoji that I use periodically on in text
messaging is not a happy face or
anything it's the Albanian flag it's
completely random it means nothing
except I don't think I've ever gotten
the Emoji oh you haven't well we don't
text enough you would you eventually the
man you will crack up I'm looking at my
wife comes over to me and goes I'm just
curious why do you use our flag as your
emoji he well how the hell does this man
know that yeah how does he I I don't
know I don't to this minute unless
you've been Tex but I don't all I'm
saying is that that's a that's you work
you work in your work in life you want
to touch people with good better ideas
and then you find that some have been
and I don't exaggerate there are seven
what s billion people on earth I I
always know how many I haven't touched
much more than I think of those I did
but nevertheless that's
gratifying uh there there there was also
obviously there are it's interesting
there are many differences among
conservatives on a whole host of issues
but on certain fundamental issues there
really does seem to be agreement
including the genius of the founders of
the United States and I believe it was
genius when I will say the term and it
strikes most Americans as worthy of a
yawn limited government they don't
understand the Holiness the goodness of
that
idea governments created every single
genocide of the 20th century why people
put Faith in big government they laugh
at people who put faith in God in Christ
in in the Bible are you kidding in terms
of irrationality you win heads down with
faith in government yeah I mean most of
the killing Mo 99% the only
non-governmental Slaughter of the 20th
century was the hus slaughtering the
tosis that was the only non-governmental
Slaughter but 99% of the of the 100
million
slaughtered not not combat not not these
are not combatants right not people in
in the War uh was done by big government
so when you think of the Albanian guy
and the Emoji right limited government
what Jordan's trying to do here is tell
a better story are are you shocked in
all of your years doing this that
somehow this is the question I've been
asking everybody that the West did not
sell the story or that we gave up the
story or we got confused about the story
or whatever it is that has led us to
where we're at now
I'll tell you how not shocked I am I
began lecturing at 21 I have a very
strange life but so I'm just making the
your listeners aware of that I I know
how odd that is but I did I began
speaking at 21 by the age of 25 I would
look at
audiences and I would say to them and of
course these were my parents' age
basically adult
audiences and I would say to them your
motto has been we're going to give our
children everything we didn't have and
you did the problem is you didn't give
us anything you did have MH you and I
meant patriotism love of country God the
centrality of the
community all it was all gone in the
name of uh no more war and no more
poverty and by the way that's
fascinating to me because you're talking
two generations off me correct because
you're one generation me you're talking
about your parents gener correct so that
really shows the how how long right so
when people say correctly the greatest
Generation in terms of the the the
Depression and World War II they were
awesome in terms of of continuing the
American story The Western story to use
Jordan's terminology zilch not not all
obviously my parents did my parents
raised me to believe I was the luckiest
Jew in history to live in America and he
wrote his thesis in college on anti
semitism in America and he still told me
we were the luckiest Jews in the history
of the world yes my Dad wow his senior
class thesis City College of New York
was an anti about Jews not allowed at
the country clubs Jews not allowed to
live in certain places Harvard having a
quota on Jews and still said correctly
this was the greatest place Jews ever
lived so I know this is obviously a very
sort of sangen and depressing moment for
a lot of people but I saw you a couple
days ago in LA at this RFK uh Speech or
at this RFK talk that we were doing and
you know you talk about defending
America that's what you've been doing
for your whole life but also defending
the Jewish people and and spreading the
ideas of Judaism uh this is this is a
terrible moment in our history and I
feel like that must weigh on you
probably in a way that is even deeper
than than most people who are just kind
of getting caught
up it weighs on
me but interestingly it doesn't Shock
Me Rabbi Joseph tskin and I wrote when
we were 30 a book that's still in print
Third Edition why the Jews the reason
for
anti-Semitism and we cite the 2,000
year- old line and maybe even older than
that and it's in every Passover service
in every generation they arise to
annihilate us and I always point out not
to persecute us not to enslave us to
annihilate the Hebrew word I know Hebrew
well is to make an end to
us so this is going to sound over the
top to many of your listeners I don't
care uh but it feeling comfortable is
less important than knowing
truths so I
think as many Jews
do especially my age I was I was born
after World War II but not
much and
and I I have thought all of my life what
was it like for a Jew to enter the gas
chamber I mean it's it's a dark thought
but if you don't think about dark things
it's cuz you're you're you're somewhat
of a coward you're not willing to look
at the
darkness and so I would think what was
it like and I and I came up with an idea
that is startling even to most Jews I
said I think there was really only One
Division among the Jews in the gas
Chambers not not religious not religious
not intellectual not intellectual not
rich certainly not rich not
poor basically nothing the biggest
Division I believe was between those who
knew why they were being killed and
those who
didn't there is there is no doubt in my
mind that evil concentrates on
Jews first Never Last non-jews are
spectacularly foolish if they think that
Hitler is a Jewish Problem only they
think Hamas is only a Jewish Problem the
stupidity and the self-destructive
nature of that belief is is is
Indescribable had had the non-jewish
world understood that that those who
hate Jews and wish to hurt them will
hurt you
next uh they would have stopped Hitler
and tens of millions of non-jews would
have been saved okay just for the record
okay same with Kamas if you don't
understand they are this generation's
Nazis you are lying to yourself and that
is the worst sin you can commit it is
one thing if you lie to others There's
Hope for you if you lie to yourself
there's no hope for
you and so I I am not shocked at the
barbarity of Jew haters not in the least
it doesn't shock me I am angered I it's
it's depressing but it's not shocking so
that's my answer to your question about
what I'm going through is it the great
irony of the Jews like it's sort of
baked in the code baked in the code as
you just said this is something that's
told at Passover that my grandparents
and their grandparents and the great and
it always happens so it's almost like in
an odd way these things are inevitable
well do you think that means that
that our inev that our constant uh the
constant desire to destroy this minority
is I mean if it's Bak in the code that
that's kind of upsetting the Jews
brought uh the Jews brought the god of
the Bible the Bible the Ten Commandments
Adam and Eve the uh Christianity brought
all of this into the world those who
hate those things hate the Jews the idea
that God judges me on my behavior not on
my faith alone is uh is a hateful idea
to fundamentalist Muslims for whom God
judges solely on whether you are whether
you believe in Allah and the Quran or
not that's it and if you don't uh as
ibben khaldun the greatest Arab writer
who ever lived wrote it is we are the
greatest religion because we kill to
make we kill people if they don't
convert whereas Jews and Christians
don't do that he actually wrote that I I
cite him in my book uh still the best
Hope on America Islam and and uh and and
leftism so
uh people don't want to acknowledge this
that you from the river to the Sea
Palestine will be free means annihilate
Israel Israel is from The River To The
Sea yeah so it that's all it means it
means exterminate a state there is no
other example of that in the world today
so uh this this so the answer you asked
me about it so here you like this in the
the the the holiest Jewish text after
the Bible and about, 18800 years ago the
rabis asked why are the Jews
hated and they spent very little time on
the subject they spend as I often tell
people they spend a whole volume on
whether whether you can eat an egg born
on on a Jewish holy day and and I'm not
mocking it I'm just saying it's it's
filled with Rel very long yeah you know
discussions of such subjects yeah but
anti-Semitism gets a few paragraphs
because there was no complexity and they
said it with a play on Hebrew words
which any anyone listening will
understand because the the words sound
so similar the the word for hatred is
sin the word for sin as in Mount Si
where the Ten Commandments was given is
is
sini sini and Sina sound almost
identical correct yeah they have
different consonants in Hebrew but
that's irrelevant they sound virtually
the same they said the great Sina comes
from sini the Jews got the Torah at
Sinai the Jews are hated for the Torah
and they're absolutely right and and
therefore I have argued my whole life
without
making really great progress I admit it
that the answer to anti-Semitism is the
cause of anti-Semitism spread the
torah's values no one has to be a Jew
Judaism does does not hold you that you
have to be a Jew to be saved but the
best values in the history of the world
are contained in those five books at
which is why I'm writing my rational
Bible series on each of those five books
to explain the all the great answers to
evil are in those five books so if the
if the persecution or the hatred is
baked in is the irony of that or the
salvation of that that the survival is
also baked in right isn't every story
every holiday they tried to kill us they
did Kill A bunch of us but let's eat and
we're still here so that maybe is the is
the magic is that the hope I well yeah
well the that the religious Jew goes on
one Rabbi who lost all of his children
the Nazis murdered every one of his
children like six or eight of them and
they asked him how how do you still
believe and he had an interesting answer
he said for the believer there are no
questions and for the atheist there are
no answers he's overstating it but but
his point point is well
taken he he was not prepar oh this my
children were killed by bad people
therefore there is no God it didn't
comport to him I don't know why God
allowed this to happen that that's an
unanswerable mystery fine but
nevertheless for the atheist nothing
makes sense Everything Is Random
including life itself at least the
religious person oh yeah God created
Life The Atheist beats me me it happened
really that's their answer beats me so
one way or another Prager we will do
this again because we
survive we'll probably do this again
next week I assume at your house right
so wait you bet we the Jews or we you
and I I meant both oh that's great I
love it I love you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of time topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification Bell